ahora que hemos planteado nuestra
integral de superficie vamos a intentar
parametrizar la superficie y algo que
hay que pensar es tomar todos los
valores del círculo unitario déjenme
marcarlo aquí digamos este es nuestro
círculo unitario ok vamos
de hecho asombrar lo que es justamente
la intersección de nuestro cilindro con
el plano xy verdad entonces tomamos
todos estos puntos y los valores z ya
vimos que son función de ye de hecho de
hecho sabemos que aquí podemos despejar
como se está igual a 2 - y entonces ya
que tenemos esto visto podemos obtener
cada punto de la superficie porque en
cada punto de este círculo unitario le
podemos asignar de gm lo pongo un
poquito mejor le podemos asignar aquí en
cada punto le podemos asignar un punto
de la superficie entonces visto como
como una función de esa forma entonces
vamos a buscar todos los puntos primero
del círculo unitario
me pinto estos ejes rota 2
y aquí está el eje y
y vamos a poner también el eje x
ok con eso basta y ahora vamos a pintar
aquí nuestro círculo unitario
keith más o menos estoy haciendo mi
mejor esfuerzo para pintar
unitario
más o menos de esta forma y ahora
buscamos todos los puntos interiores de
este círculo entonces voy a introducir
un primer parámetro que voy a llamar
teta teta
la letra griega theta va a indicar el
ángulo en el cual nos estamos moviendo
para recorrer este círculo que entonces
theta lo que me está midiendo
esencialmente es el ángulo que yo voy
recorriendo al moverme en el círculo
entonces si teta es este ángulo y yo
puedo moverme desde este punto alrededor
del círculo pues tetas sólo le queda a
tener valores entre 0 y 2 para entonces
z está entre 0 y 2 pi muy bien ahora
otro valor que yo tengo que introducir u
otro parámetro es el valor de r donde r
lo que me va a estar haciendo es medir
la distancia que yo esté del origen del
del origen de las coordenadas del 0 0 al
círculo ok entonces qué es lo que voy a
hacer por ejemplo fijándome en alguna en
un radio fijo al moverme a lo largo o al
variar el parámetro theta lo que va a
estar haciendo es recorrer
alrededor del origen con un radio fijo
entonces y ahora variamos el radio puedo
ir recorriendo más círculos de tal
suerte que yo voy a rellenar todo está
este círculo unitario o también lo
puedes pensar de la siguiente forma que
si yo fijo el ángulo y después le
permito mover r entonces yo puedo ir
moverme desde el origen hasta el extremo
que es el círculo unitario entonces esto
nos dice que el radio no está o sea no
puede pasar de uno ni de cero es decir
el radio es más grande que cero pero
menor o igual que uno ok entonces con
esto dicho vamos a utilizar
trigonometría para expresar x y y ceta
de esta forma porque x es esta distancia
que no es otra cosa más que ere josé no
de teta también tenemos por mismos
argumentos que ya es igual a ere seno de
teta simplemente es cosa de construir un
triángulo rectángulo y considerar este
ángulo teta y ahora bien cómo obtenemos
está pues zeta de acá arriba sabemos que
es despejando z es igual a 2 - y por lo
tanto por lo tanto tenemos que zeta va a
ser igual a 2 - jacques ere s no de teta
2 - r seno de teta ok entonces ya para
concluir tenemos una parametrización de
nuestra superficie en el plano x y
esencialmente tenemos las famosas
coordenadas polares y z es 2 - rc 90
donde r seno de teteyé entonces déjenme
poner aquí ese va a ser igual en la
primera en la primera entrada va a ser
coseno dt está por y que es nuestro
vector dirección en la dirección x más
r seno de teta que va en la dirección
vertical que es el vector j + 2 - r seno
de teta en la dirección
zeta